dans mon brave avait tout pour lui
il avait gagné des milliards sillonné le
monde sur des yachts de luxe et possède
les propriétés dans les plus beaux
endroits du monde
il avait bâti un empire en partant de
rien
des milliers de personnes la plaie
l'homme le plus puissant du monde et map
lors il l'appelle
monsieur faisait pas comment j'en suis
arrivée là tu a négligé ta famille il va
devoir rester dans la peau de chat
jusqu'à ce que tu tu rachètes regarde
sérieusement et je déteste les chats
c'est bien pour ça que c'est par noyer
moi s'il vous plaît
young boys est un dogme c'est l'un des
25 zones et d'autres empires from
scratch dans ce domaine
non